bình dưới dự thái lan và các bù trí là đặc bức bảo dây đoạn nhạy cảm, sau hai ngày dấu chanh,
khiến hàng chục người thương vong trong bối cảnh đó, tiến bố sẵn sàng bánh và đảm phán từ cả hai bên được xem là bước đi tích cực,
nhằm chẳng viết cơ lều thang thành dùng bộ phụ trang vàn dịt.
Phát biểu dấu khóc kiến của hộ đồng bảo an, bối dự tham dự của đại dịt các bù trí ở và thái lan,
tại sự các bù trí et tại liên hợp quốc trí à kèo khẳng định, các bù trí et đẹg gịn bánh nè lập tức và vô điều kiện,
đồng thời kêu gọi giả quốc trình chấp một cách hoặc bình.
Phê phần mình phát biểu chức của khóc kiến người phát bồn bộ ngoại giáo Thái Lan,
đi con tê và lan của ra tuy bố, thái lan sẵn sàng đam phán.
Theo bộ ít tế Thái Lan, hơn 183 gình người dân nước này đã được sư tán khỏi các khu vực bên dưới,
xung đột khiến mấy lâm người Thái Lan thiệt mạng, hộ mười bốn xanh thường và một bình xí và bốn mề sống người khác bị thương.
Chúng khi đó phía các bù trí ở sân yện có ít nhất một xanh thường thiệt mạng và năm người bị thương.
Chính quyền có bù trí cũng đã sử tả năng gình bốn chăm bà mề sống ổ dân đến lời an toàn.